on this episode we talk about daily
rituals Facebook following count and
what do you do when you have too much
business
[Music]
this is
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 117 of the askgaryvee
show super pumped 117 we've got a full
house in here sin white space sighs I
don't know if you guys saw what I just
said Irene Icke named you said
stunwin let's just um well we haven't
you see someone has you know little og
action I know you made a little cameo in
the d-roc film that came out I'm super
excited about that fired up I was on the
west coast so uh no episodes this week
so we did some best stuff stuff
obviously the behind the scenes things
so I'm really excited I've got a lot of
energy
oh and you guys said you like three
questions just now via email I know so
it's been an it's been an intense it's
been it's been fun but I want some of
these that I just sent you so hack along
the way here in real time and appreciate
all of you so India let's get into the
show get into the show
Niles asked why doesn't Gary Vee read
books doesn't he see the value well he
writes books himself an Eli I don't read
books because of a couple things one I'm
very inefficient at reading so it takes
me a long long time and the truth is I
don't think I actually grasp what I read
as a matter of fact something very
interesting has happened over the last
six to eight months here at vaynermedia
when I see that something comes in my
inbox that's a very important piece of
business and it's a very long email
aka more than 18 words I call a
five-minute meeting because in five
minutes and my staff will tell you like
you won't see the body language here but
I'm saying it for them it's insane in a
meeting I basically don't even let
people finish saying what they're saying
because I've grasped it but if they sent
me that same comment in four sentences I
literally wouldn't even know what was
going on and so I don't read because I
don't think it's an efficient
transaction of transforming information
into my brain I really don't wanna books
is something I need to take very
seriously but the truth is I don't read
because the way I like to consume
information is living it I know that
sounds weird but it's just the truth I
really do think the reason that I've
been able to be an anomaly is I know
that that's probably not the norm most
people do read books like as a matter of
fact it's crazy that the internet came
along because if the internet hadn't
come along I wouldn't have written or
read in my life like I was well on my
way if I was you know if you know I'm
sure there's some 50 to 80 year olds who
are watching the show right now are
listening to the show who are like me
who realize holy crap they really didn't
write or read from like 24 to like 45
pre-internet stuff so uh I write books
because I know so many people do read I
know some people do learn from
highlighting the [ __ ] out of the book I
don't and so you can't be religious or
romantic about these things just because
I write them doesn't mean I need to read
them and vice versa and so the reason I
don't do it is because I don't find
value in it for me and I highly
recommend a lot of you start really
auditing yourself and understanding are
you doing stuff that actually doesn't
bring any value to you just because
that's what society and the world and
you have always done because the answer
is yes Raymond asks what daily rituals
do you practice to keep focused Raymond
that's a good question daily rituals to
keep focused you know now that I'm a
year and two days into my physical
regimen that is uh what you would think
is one of the things I do but I don't I
do not find that my working out has done
anything for me mentally I really don't
I don't feel any different mentally
today than I did a year ago
I don't sleep better the only thing
that's happened is I just look way
better and and you know that's that I'm
sure there's plenty but I'll probably
live a lot longer I mean there's that
bang I feel much stronger by the way
travelling is where I'm really feeling
it like pick like just little silly
things like grabbing my you know like my
suitcase
I think I only have one ritual which is
uh in parallel to the way I live my life
even right now as I'm talking to you
guys there's a little part of my brain
that's always moving it's just like
think of it as like a hamster wheel and
it's always just reminding myself to
keep things in perspective right I think
my daily ritual how is the question
phrasing in India to keep me focused I
think the one thing that keeps me
focused is the perspective of
understanding how lucky I am how good
life really is how the things I complain
about are not that big of a deal in the
scheme of things how at moment's notice
I can get a text right now I'll film
this show and have the tragedy of my
life happen and and every second that
doesn't happen how thankful I should be
for that because those are real
scenarios these are things that you and
so many of us deal with on a daily basis
now that I have a 530 person company you
know HR sends me an email inevitably
every week to two weeks of very scary
things like people's families having
tragedies of death or people being
diagnosed with illness like just real
stuff real stuff
I am stunningly capable outside of New
York Jets football to understand in
check in emotion how how nothing like
that how 99% of things don't matter and
so my daily ritual is actually my ritual
that I keep at an every second day it's
my moment every second ritual of keeping
myself in check to recognizing what is
important versus what's not sure I get
frustrated and concerned and worried but
it never has a sustained level of a
feeling because I just put things in
perspective so well I'm so thankful for
that gear I really wish I knew how to
teach it I think the only thing I try to
do is put it out to you guys I'm hoping
that somebody's like geez that seemed
like there was hope you're looking at me
you're listening to me right now it's
like gee that sounds fun you're right it
is like like I'm a very outrageously
stunningly over-the-top happy person
because of this gear it is very
difficult for me to have sustained
unhappiness because of this vehicle and
it also allows me and I really do
believe this
allows me to affect the people around me
whether they're consuming me on daily
basis or they work with me to actually
level themselves stellen as someone who
I find very cynical and different than
me straight up no [ __ ] because I
don't care and you know that don't
[ __ ] me
okay do you feel yes that this how long
have you been jamming together now
eighteen month where we at now it varies
well over two years I'm sorry in these
two years do you feel that you the
answer I don't know how much you were
listening you seem like you were working
which is a nice change of pace summer do
you feel no [ __ ] no [ __ ] do you
feel that you've moved at any level to
be more optimistic bigger perspective
happier
oh forget to talk about it I know it cuz
I can see it from afar so I'm pumped to
hear that but I'm curious how you
quantify like how much or how or what or
talk I would say that the the thing that
you all that you say that resonated with
me the most is is the whole like you're
100% in control of your situation and
like don't [ __ ] about it like grab it
and you've changed in that way yeah in a
big way
absolutely yeah you're right I think
about you three years ago you complained
more I've complained a lot yeah no
really yeah and you feel more in control
a hundred percent yeah if I have a
problem it's everything is fixable as
opposed to and talk to me and Alyssa as
somebody who's when did you start
watching wine Larry TV 2007-present the
difference of being this said I listened
very carefully I'm a good listener the
thing you said that resonated with me
you followed me for a long time how long
have you been at vaynermedia three years
this month great so for almost a full
year you weren't as inner circle with me
was it the was it watching the execution
of that non complaining that triggered
it or was it just momentum or what I'm
trying to figure out then what I want to
do for them yeah is what's the
difference between what they are
experiencing which is what you
experienced which is you're listening to
it versus clearly being able to see it
and real light like you see all the
money but you know the insanity to that
you know I know what it is okay it's
it's that you encourage people to take
control of the situation and what
happens is the first time somebody
actually attacks on that
and says I have a problem with this
person and instead of bitching and
complaining about it they actually take
control the situation and they say hey
this is a problem how do we fix it
people are afraid to do that they think
it's gonna backfire they think I'm not
allowed to give that person feedback or
I'm not allowed to act on this because
it's not my job or I'm not senior enough
or whatever and the first time you do it
and it doesn't backfire and it actually
works because you asked for what you
wanted is like oh [ __ ] that's actually
really empowering and let me teach you
about scale that's exam and then what I
know and I'm gonna give you a little
love here is going from that what he
just said which is complaining and not
doing anything about it to the next step
which is doing something about it but
what Steve has done unlike others that
I'm super-pumped they're just doing it
what's team has done that I've noticed
is not only that then empowering others
to do the same and that my friends is
scale that my friends is how you go from
a small base to a big base when you are
so religious and you suffocate all the
wrong and you try to teach and you have
people that level up to it so that saves
you time but then some breakthrough and
actually teach it as well and help me
scale it and know how much of a religion
is that's when you start really scaling
it and that's who the hell knows how we
got to this point I don't even remember
the question daily ritual
that's my ritual and not only is it my
ritual it's my religion it's my passion
and it is probably fundamentally why I
do this damn show because I'm so
desperate for you guys to do the same
because it's just way better it's right
meerkat what's up the cat sir meerkat
here probably not they liked it they
felt it they're saying they're pretty
happy it's good you too all right
you like seeing yourself majored in
acting I get it I get it
I hate seeing myself yeah
well I'm joking I live for it yeah
that's why I do the show by Brownrigg
asks alright Gary Vee you're big on
authentic marketing but when does it go
from building trust with the audience to
[ __ ] man that's TMI too much information
um so I I don't think we the people that
put out the content get to judge what
TMI is I think the consumer judges
what's too much information and so as
you can think now and let your whole
mind go you've got all sorts of people
that are whether in social or real
mainstream media that you deem put out
too much information or not enough
information and so I'm a big fan of the
market deciding and I think the way you
learn how the market decides is to
listen to the market for me you put out
stuff and you see what they come back to
for example there's a vine that I put
out where I'm sitting in a toilet Danny
the craziest place I find is this this
that might've been to my TMI for people
you know I did it because I'm curious of
what - TMI is and I think one I think
breaks down to two things number one the
market decides right like and we've seen
that right I mean you've seen no
question there was a time in period
where people thought Elvis shaking his
hips was too much information I would
call that team compared to what Miley
Cyrus did at the MTV Music Awards 18
months ago I would consider that team -
what XYZ is gonna do six years from now
on whatever we're paying her got a
Netflix show right so like live show
right like I'm so like I think that um
things evolved the market evolves but I
really think of this as nothing in the
middle the market decides and then you
get the decide we've referenced kind of
the work you know it's been funny this
we had a an episode where I really got
hardcore about my family thing and it's
been bubbling up I've been getting a lot
of positive feedback from a lot of
friends and family about how little I
put out on Misha and Xander and Lizzie
and how I do keep my family life pretty
private in the scheme of how TMI I am
you know I decided that Lizzie decided
that we decided that and the occasional
picture would be fun and and would never
be deemed as to TMI but we decided that
is for us TMI and so I think you deeply
have to be authentic to what's right for
you you can't force it right like you
know like you just can't force it like I
would definitely maybe about another
year maybe in another 18 months I
definitely am gonna give a keynote
without my shirt on many would deem that
as to TMI yet you probably won't see
Zander until he's like 17 right so I
mean like it's just you've got to decide
and then the market decides right like
if people are engaging with your stuff
and there's a lot of Instagram girls
that are putting out content that many
would deem is too TMI but the market
sure likes it and if it works for them
that's how you have to live your life
and so you do you you do you there is
nobody deciding between the sides you
and the market that's the way it should
be and there's always this nice balance
and if you're fortunate if you're lucky
what you're willing to put out there
willing to consume and are happy with it
and that's the Mendoza line we're all
looking for
hey there Gary this is Matthew Adams
over at Hilton Head house of jerky and I
want to let you know I tried that thing
with telling everybody thank you with
the video on Twitter and it has worked
better than good
the problem I'm having right now is I've
got so many new tweets coming in and
some new people following me it's
becoming a little overwhelming how do
you handle that thanks take great take
care and have a great day this is an
interesting question house of jerky
there's a very interesting question you
know the truth is I can never like fake
the funk on this show like like I think
one of things that works for me is like
my reactions always my reactions so
since I've already seen this video I'm
not as pissed as I was three weeks ago
or whenever the hell I saw where I
literally housed a jerky and I love you
literally wanted to punch you directly
in your mouth because this really pissed
me off because like like Jesus Christ
like like hey help me fix my business
and make my business better cool here do
this awesome
my business is better but now there's
like too much of this I mean it is so
insane like you know and again you
such a lovely dude that I don't want
like I'm doing this never just by the
way I'm never answering these questions
just for the person at hand it is the
collective answer and so I hope and I
mean this my man I hope you're being
tongue-in-cheek with me and you just
wanted to get on the show or what I
really hope because if because if you're
not being tongue-in-cheek with me you're
you're an insane loser anybody in
anybody anybody who has a problem with
too many things going well are pre-wired
for failure and that hurts like and I
really the truth is the reason I
probably took the show and like it said
bringing us oh I can taste that that's
not your case but I do think that
there's many people listening and
watching that are the case and the
thought that you could ever complain
about success is so insane to me and
listen you know maybe I have a visceral
reaction to this because business
associates have done this with me in my
career and I can't there's so much to
complain about that is a valid if you're
willing to mean the show as you could
tell I'm not even interested in doing
that at all you know I've said on the
show the biggest thing I admire in the
world is my mom's inability to complain
it's something I'm massively proud of I
really try not to do it and the thought
to complain about hey you gave me a
tremendous piece of a business strategy
stick with me here
so we're [ __ ] free stick with me here
it worked good things are happening to
me good things are happening to me and
now there's too much good things
happening to me help me reconcile this
good thing that's happening to me that
is bonkers [ __ ] USA that is that is
insane and I right here lying in the
sand on the show to you vaynernation I'm
telling you that is a line I'm not
allowing you to cross I am not allowing
you you any of you ever in your life
ever I'm choking it the [ __ ] out you are
on allowed if you want to be homies
friends even borderline acquaintances
you are not allowed to complain about
success let me let me help you with your
problem shut your [ __ ] business down
because if you're gonna complain about
good things happening you've
that's insane complain when you're like
down to your last penny not when you
have too many customers you know what
you need to do stop bullshitting but
sleep less [ __ ] don't watch TV like I
don't know like don't make a video with
Gary Vee answer somebody's [ __ ]
question got it I found it I did find it
I found it later I found that place late
I found the place late and how's the
jerky no I love you but like and again
my proxy is I have to think like you
know you're enjoying the process but
like you can't complain about success I
mean if you're complaining about success
just shut it all down
that got it and I get it
fans to fans asks Gary Vee your facebook
numbers don't reflect how influential
you are how do you explain that to
clients um that's a good question you
know it's funny I mean like I think
people I think people are lost let me
explain
here's how I explain it to clients I
assume what you're saying is Gary you've
built a personal brand and you only have
three hundred thirty six thousand
followers on Facebook and there's a lot
of people that have way more and your
influence is bigger and like and I like
you bands fans being very nice like I
think you're bigger than that I see
other people that have four hundred
thousand or a hundred eighty thousand
that are way less than you how do you
explain that I explained it very simply
my goal in life is not to amass facebook
fans I explain it by saying look at all
these people that have way more social
media followers who sell nine books when
their book comes out and I sell hundreds
of thousands I explain and say look you
know how I tell you I'm good at building
businesses look at this building called
business called vaynermedia that you
know three years ago the three million
and it's gonna do 65 million that's good
right I explained it because a top-line
how many followers do you have on social
media proxy is straight [ __ ] you
want more [ __ ] Twitter followers go
to ebay calm and buy them and you trick
them like I can go buy a bunch of
Facebook pages and merge it like
because it doesn't mean anything cuz a
top line awareness number has nothing to
do with the thing that I care about the
most in the world
which is selling stuff show me it all
the way through show it all the way
through because the amount of people
that can create perception it's like
being pretty cool you're pretty but are
you a good person because pretty only
gets you so far
cool you have 500,000 fans on Facebook
and if you're saying that you're a
business leader
are you making money do you sell stuff
like are you good like that and so I
explained it very easily as you can tell
because I promise you that Pepsi and
Toyota and Unilever and Budweiser and
all those characters that hire
vaynermedia could care less about how
many followers the CEO has they care a
lot more about selling [ __ ] that was
pretty solid yeah meerkat thinks that's
right right
I know it sound a little bit of a delay
Andrew but yeah they think that's
correct yeah question of the day stun
one deffence you've made your glorious
return you get to ask the question that
day what video game are you playing
right now at least you're consistent
thank you so much for the support of the
show if you've gotten this far it means
that you're pretty passionate about the
show and I'm gonna ask for a right hook
animation serious right
[Music]
I need reviews on iTunes because even
though top-line numbers don't matter as
I said they do matter because they're a
proxy that's why you ask the show
question of a show it's all the clouds
and the dirt right and so if you're
listening if you're watching it would
mean the world to me whether you give me
a one star because you think this shows
a piece of crap or you give me five but
I'm looking for reviews direction let's
mean like a right hook graphic
fanimation do something good you can ask
questions I'll keep answering
[Music]